olá muito boa tarde a todos vão gostar
aqui deixando só no minuto agradecer é
uma mata a um convite da organização a
primeira pessoa que falou comigo é
manuela e oclaro e aceitei logo já tinha
ouvido falar o que era o tempo não sabia
muito bem o que é que era foi investigar
e portanto agradecer não só o convite
como também aquilo que aprendi antes mas
consegue perceber o que queria dizer
terra e aí fica claro que nem sempre o
pacto tecnologia não tanto que para isso
o único isto é uma vergonha que não têm
sequer uma apresentação é 11 no
entretenimento também não tenho e então
design claramente que não tem nada fazer
né e conforme figura anexa e por isso de
repente olhei pro chez isso é injustiça
é estás tramado como externo norte e
aquela coisa aqui no norte do es muitas
jogadas tramadas mas assim fraco e mas
de qualquer maneira vamos aceitar o
desafio agora será manuela camisa toda a
sua equipa ou fluir ignorais a susanna
leão é a floresta oliveira que falou
comigo é que a substituição que acabou
por um microfone e mas garantiu que isto
não ia falhar porque o quanto foi oo e
15 no lugar do outro não é só que não
facilitação e por isso eu tenho certeza
que ia ter um ataque de nervos e e
admirei porque estava com a habilitação
estava praticava não é é é saem mesmo
sendo do norte não disse nenhuma maneira
é este é um mito como é evidente é essa
também a maquiadora também susana ao por
uma maquiagem disse que não havia
nenhuma imperfeição simpatia ou se foi
por pena foi um sorriso
bom meus créditos é porque eu estou aqui
eu estou aqui porque o final da história
é portugal que são universitários três
livros e tal
no início da minha história
não foi nada assim o início da minha
história foi completa foi desastrosa e o
chumbo e duas vezes no quarto é no
sétimo ano da minha vida digamos fazia
pra mim pouco sentindo era humilde e
profundamente triste como falta de
autoestima é digamos é com tudo aquilo
que strass nossa jacinto um companheiro
olhava e dizia que estava completamente
a passar ao lado da vida é que quer na
discriminação que sentia parte a
discriminação que sentia por parte dos
produtores e nada fazia sentido para mim
até que mesmo com as meninas também era
a mesma coisa
as meninas também não me venham se
apresentava muito comigo apesar das
vezes dizer a ele eu gosto muito tempo
depois acrescentavam frase assassina mas
é só comigo
é hora e no final da minha gestão você
gosta mesmo de mim mas não apenas comigo
lá até que apareceu qualquer coisa na
minha vida e preciso mudar quase tudo
foi dito e perceber que digamos do meu
esforço poderia resultar qualquer coisa
consegue conviver com derrotas com
vitórias quer conquistar e digamos a
socializar a criar empatia com os outros
respeitar aquilo que o treinador dizia e
sobretudo conseguir vencer os meus medos
que eram muitos e não era medo dos
outros era medo de mim próprio me
espalhar medo do ridículo medo de tudo e
1 mil com 2 13 anos
de repente já tem a vida com as feita no
hormônio a sua esperança não era nenhuma
ea um edital que esta não há nenhuma
criança esteja triste que consiga
aprender nem criança nem e dutos
quando nós temos três conseguimos
aprender alguma coisa com evidentemente
que não e portanto esta é base do
problema é com a cozinha ter sucesso no
atletismo
a pouco e pouco com a ajuda de todos
de todos os meus companheiros cheguei a
companhia no final quem trouxe uma
grande auto estima e é os consultados
nos tudo como está não é pouca e pouca
melhorar é tem atingido em níveis muito
muito aceitáveis porque eu vim falar no
atletismo brasileiro foi o maior número
de equipes não é por causa disso é
porque as competências que eu ganhei no
atletismo e podia ter falado aqui na
dança
queria ter falado no teatro podia ter
falado na música nas artes é imensa as
coisas porque essa dessas coisas vão
aparecer competências que nós vamos
ganhar e portanto a minha vida é depois
que o rei normal entre nuvens em
portugal eu sempre fui professor
universitário é até que chegou uma
altura da minha vida que eu pensei assim
passei toda aqui o problema e outra saiu
e só quem passa por um problema do
insucesso escolar é incluir cêntimos ea
pior coisa do mundo sentimos até que os
nossos pais deixaram dos amaros porque
estão tristes conosco será que eu posso
ajudar os outros e na realidade
concelhia escrever um livro mas como eu
diga às vezes hoje os alunos já têm um
digamos faço palestras também o sucesso
escolar não foram buscar a casa eu
escrevi porque achava que devia escrever
e não sabia que ia ser publicado e
portanto foi à procura de uma editora
que percebeu e aí é minha vida com isso
realmente usar em relação a tudo aquilo
que eu fazia porque conseguia ser
chamado para fazer palestras porque
viram que tinha aquela lógica bem é você
fala do insucesso escolar e tons que
ainda não viu banheiros onde nós aqui
temos venha cá falar com ele e pra onde
eu fui pelo país o verão e atitudes
sobre os resultados e mostravam que em
30% e r 30 por cento das notas
superiores em relação à aquela mostra é
que eu trabalhar e ea partir daí
começaram realmente a pena para escrever
mais livros é ter chegado é que o outro
filho de matos 20 é com certeza
evidentemente um ponto alto foi também e
convidar por escrito com a nota triste
do tamanho saída
e digamos passaia ter esta missão é esta
é esta coisa que me anima
por que sempre eu consigo usar a vida de
algum destes miúdos porque eu saio
já estive nessa situação é fico
evidentemente muito satisfeito é o que
queria dizer é que é na maior parte das
vezes reprimidos não tem muita culpa da
questão do insucesso e identificar
certos atores e às vezes perguntas assim
mas como é que o motivo meu filho o meu
neto para o sucesso escolar
assim nessa questão não só por assim
desta forma eu tenho que perguntar e
como é que um motivo para a vida não é
porque vida vai para além do isso é do
sesc lar
não é que eu tivemos que dar pra vida
está mudando conceitos claro está a
motivar perder tudo eo e naquela
perspectiva do que eu quero
evidentemente uma criança seja luís
a escola hoje em dias tal como está é
tem muita dificuldade em passado digamos
esta alegria às crianças um mundo mudou
bastante é dizer que ele não venha que
evidentemente pôr a culpa na escola
escola nos últimos 40 anos foi uma
escola que pretendeu chegar a todos e
quando dizemos a todos é uma escola
municipal na escola plural uma escola
democrática e ia mesmo que ser assim mas
transformou também numa escola muito
objetiva a base da nota do passa não
passa é a base da imposição eu vou usar
esse momento um peeling aquilo que nós
chamamos o museu ensinar e ensinar ela
qualquer coisa que nos de frio ouvido
porque o infinito e prendas e eu vou te
ensinar é e vou te ensinar o que é que o
que eu acho que tu deves aprender e
portanto isto e ligamos uma coisa muito
pouco amigável porque nós não podemos
esquecer que as nossas crianças e dos
nossos jovens aprendem quando querem com
quem querem nem todas as pessoas criam
empatia quando que era e como quer aí ou
seja nós
aprendemos todos da mesma maneira foi
falar do cérebro e um cardiologista nós
percebemos que observe como funciona o
coração dos nossos professores na maior
parte das vezes não sabem muito bem como
funciona o cérebro de uma criança é
quando nós entramos em pânico por
exemplo o cérebro reptiliano naquela
altura prevalece e e saem práticas de
meditação e ver que foram faladas e ó
que coisas deste gênero não essas coisas
não são tratadas nós passamos a vida a
dizer as crenças para sossegado al
ghamdi ensinou parar em suas jogadas
técnicas que foram faladas
como é que ela para sua escada cala não
digas disparates e depois mais tarde nas
empresas
vamos vamos falar do prêmio se tornem
olha vamos lá ter inglês nem que já tem
malucas daqui é capaz de fazer qualquer
coisa e de repente já estão
desbloqueados não é cala não diga
disparates
temos medo do ridículo eu também
todos temos medo de falhar a prestar à
vontade não sai mesmo tô não é os pais
tinham linhas até estava dizendo que
estava dando alguns índices vêm do egito
em doha ficou nos nota no seu corpo é
uma coisa que me acalma
mas eu encontrei a chave digamos para
digamos marcar ao tocar o mar não é
podia ser outras coisas por isso e na
meditação e portanto cada um tem que
encontrar essa chata e portanto a nossa
escola tem que dar esse salto
qualitativo
por que ao tornar se uma escola muito
objetiva é digamos competências muito
ligadas o hemisfério cerebral direito é
escola turno e peço besteiro queria
dizer
a escola é digamos se tornou muito
limitada ontem escola o estoque em
aspectos de inteligência emocional
falamos no sono utopia na poesia não é
nunca fala aqui falar da um poema é pois
é meus e organiza andrade os teus olhos
eram pais de verdade mas sou governo do
país mas há uma grande confusão na
escola e isso não está certo ou sophia
de mello breyner não é é a sonda sobrava
uma e tentavam só pra mim nos assuntos
que então não cantam portanto quer dizer
ah
é hoje a escola tem que dar um salto
qualitativo em deixar de fugir aquela
lógica compra de complementava de várias
disciplinas e e digamos passar é fluido
numa lógica de projeto ou seja uma
escola que seja prática isto não é mais
do que eu vimos todos falar um deus que
me deixou a escola da ponte é vocês meus
queridos amigos eu posso tratar assim já
nos policiando a um pouco a aaa desde o
ano 2000 é acham que a escola ensina
disso acham que a escola põe os meninos
a criar empatias os outros por exemplo
reparem que hoje em dia as organizações
quer não é tanto é que ele e que
antigamente se dizia muito é o chamado
marrão é mas que depois não criar
empatia com os outros depois não sabia
trabalhar em grupo está a ganhar 500
tipos de dieta e entrava no nariz
empinado é espalhar só sabia falar
daquilo era uma pessoa limitada
espalhada com o pai como cidadão hoje em
dia aquilo que as organizações mas
querem são aqueles que têm competências
trabalhar em equipa criar empatia com os
outros não ser resultados adquiridos
intrigas e boatos questão da copel e
coisas assim desse gênero mas são
focados na sul tem uma inteligência
emocional muito acima da média
a escola hoje em dia mais do que formar
jovens cheias são coisas a toda hora a
informar jovens tenham cabeças saibam
pensado saiba pararam de hoje em dia
socialmente o teus nós armamos não
dizemos de placa é que estamos
optimistas aqui
portanto hoje em dia e geralmente vista
é melhor não dizer de como é que este
ponto de partida é que for porque vai
ter sempre alguém encontra contra ti não
é exclusivo da gasolina livros não nós
temos que ensinar os nossos jovens antes
de tomar decisões
só assim é que é
ainda tá se sentindo e sobretudo os
jovens têm para praticar todas todos
eles com 7 no sentido de um dia chegarem
aquilo que nós chamamos de cidadania
isso digamos é o elemento principal
sempre com alegria sempre pensando e ser
tem subido por alterar porque nós
vivemos numa sociedade
todos queremos ter como é evidente não
há mal nós temos que ter
mas temos que pensar nos nossos jovens
que antes do intervalo cedo e em leva os
meus amigos gostarem de mim não é
propriamente aquilo que eu tenho por que
não seria uma questão material mas
aquilo que eu sou um bom amigo surto nas
horas más é é que eu consegui criar
empatia e na realidade é uma boa pessoa
todos todos nós
não é época tinha 14 minutos e vinha
preparado para produtos e tá kwai
maltinas qualquer maneira talvez aqui
qualquer coisa que me dê casas ficavam
muito agradecer muito a essa média é
portanto é nestas coisas nós temos que
os jovens hoje em dia não são
estimulados são em peste motos e de
repente encabeçará a calma como é que
foi
como é que foi feito e nós temos que
promover nesses jovens um de
aprendizagens profundas em que nós da
informação o santos chegar ao
conhecimento ou seja e do conhecimento
até a santur ia talvez com um pequeno
exemplo nós eu posso explicar isso
melhor
ou seja se não souber por exemplo ocorre
é que um milagre relativa do ar e sim
apenas informação certa mas nada
agora se eu souber que há uma relação
entre a umidade relativa do ar e o bom o
mau tempo então esse já é o conhecimento
não é eu posso prever se vai a minha
gastar um tempo afastar o mau tempo se
eu tiver um comportamento preventivo no
sentido vai estar mau tempo amanhã traga
bardem amanhã trago o chapéu-de-chuva 8
não só em casa estou a prevenir uma
gripe então isso é essa
e portanto nós temos sempre esta
tecnologia nos sentidos pelos governos
aprendizagens profundas que não sejam
embutidas não é e portanto os métodos
pedagógicos está evidentemente que será
o prato e estão todos esses aspectos que
eu tenho falado é com os alunos deste
país ea responde uma questão por pra mim
o bom aluno não é só o tem boas notas e
que eu tenho de tudo aquilo que é
solidário
aquilo que é um tema nada isso é que
mais importante e é isso que vai
encontrar o homem da vida e eu no final
da vida todos nós queremos dizer olha
morreu uma boa pessoa ou então como
outra e se diz aqui no funeral dos dell
é a inter se disso e estou a mãe fui
aquilo que sempre esteve
estou bem fui aquilo que eu sempre quis
ser porque alguns de nós ao longo da
nossa vida passarmos por alturas em que
não fomos aquilo que queremos ter
durarem ouvir o rolando por rolando deus
é que imagem ao longo da vida deu foi
sempre aquilo que eu quis tentar furar o
exemplo do cão foi brilhante
eu não tenho nenhum foi protestado na
então mas de qualquer maneira é dura a
história de vida e vou terminar até para
não desgastar com uma história que
mostra que precisamos todos uns dos
outros e que às vezes a criatividade
está o de menos de espera ea imaginação
e fundamental e portanto aquela coisa de
cala não diga disparates e qualquer
coisa que não deve acontecer
aliás até já cheguei a defender que
devia haver no primeiro ciclo uma
disciplina sobre os pratos preparados
não é mais o pessoal não é sobre os
pratos de espeleologia o pensamento de o
presidente ter idéias gaza teve dizer
que há sistemas de ensino incluindo
quando as crianças começam a escrever
não diz olha essa palavra não escreve
assim vai se olhar com o conteúdo para
aquilo que ela está a dizer novo para a
sua imaginação continuou a criança
imediatamente de um kayapó todos parados
então não escreve nada não é eu vou sua
imaginação na imaginação fica pronto à
altura
para desocupar contas como verdadeira é
passa numa numa empresa que vendia
pastas de dentes que não vou dizer o
nome porque acho que é uma das cargas
aqui do tempo já que não fala em
inclusão em política não era agora que
ia estragar tudo e é estava a ver uma
reclamação porque é chinês
as caixas chegavam às lojas e algumas
não tinham tudo lá dentro é então a
abstenção reuniu de emergência é e isso
aos principais nesse range uma solução
rapidamente é s
os engenheiros reuniram é eu tinha um
orçamento vários milhões de dólares e
alcançaram uma solução muito rápida a
função era r um tapete rolante já em
final da linha onde as caixas passavam
todas uma uma é eles fizeram
seccionamento neste tapete rolante e as
caixas e se não tivesse o pitu e vial
imediatamente o tp para e ele um braço é
michele porrada essa caixa-preta
recolhia e um capítulo continuar foram
experimentar aqui funcionou e nunca mais
as reclamações só que a história não
estou aqui por causa de turismo vai
tentar que aquela máquina ligada e
desligada e ganso os administradores
desligada até alguém lá ver o que é que
está disseram o diretor que diz o
engenheiro foi então a unidade fabril
quando isso não entrou nos funcionários
não estavam habituadas não é vê-los em
jesus dias lá e disseram eu ficava em um
local denominado minha visão não tem uma
tela uma calma
nós viemos socar para perceber porque é
que a máquina será desligada algum
empregado disse é um chinês sabe isso
não dá jeito nenhum porque o tempo
passava a vida a pará e aqui uma idéia
aos teve uma outra idéia trouxe uma
ventoinha velha lá casa e puser que doar
e olha onde as caixas não tem o peso
elas vão
é um período de 36 anos que andamos à
procura então obrigado a escrever
[Aplausos]